elle était élue par les américains plus
belle femme à l'écran et quelques années
et dit tout le temps vous avez une
bouche trop grande année affres des
cheveux horrible et c'est vrai que les
stars les plus grandes stars se trouve
jamais joli c'est connu non mais je sais
je
j'ai beaucoup d'efforts mais j'arrive à
les matches j'ai appris à force étape à
force de ne plus trouver mon truc mais
j'ai tout de même des trous des photos
en photo qui sont autorisés à
photographier les gens pensent que je
suis facile je sais quoi que vous
n'auriez le plus changé ou si vous aviez
une vague et on agit comme ça et puis
pouviez changer quelque chose en
physiquement oui je n'ai pas dire qu'en
tant que je reste en qui personne n'a
peut-être pas les remarquer vous avez
joué avec les plus grands acteurs du
monde avec le lequel du parti allié sur
une île déserte peu newman non seulement
une expérience qui est très intime et
très gentil
ryan o'neal oui je les attrape
formidable belmondo très intéressant
mastroianni c'est avec lui que c'est
difficile non non pas difficile mais
moins facile que les autres
pourquoi lui dont j'avais envie non non
c'était bien mais j'avais des problèmes
avec la zone alors c'était difficile des
locuteurs salaires
je venais de commencer il était
difficile avec moi et librement
voilà c'est ça c'était inédit j'étais
carrément débutante
n'était pas sympathique mais sinon je me
suis rappelé parce que ça m'a fait
vraiment un coup et j'ai là quand je
trouvais avec des jeunes je fais
beaucoup d'efforts parce que c'est
vraiment traumatisant quand quelqu'un ne
dit même pas là pour la réplique
moi j'avais une scène d'amour a fait
avec lui il était hors cac mais on est
parti je me suis je dit ça m'a
traumatisée vous êtes obligés de faire
la réplique avec une doublure ou non
j'avais plein de joueurs qui faisait
dans les flics et les metteurs en scène
la miséricorde joke inside job
fantastique horrible et si l'on tué mais
après plus d'un an plus tard il est
devenu tout gentil avec moi parce
qu'après je suis monté un peu dans le
système métier alors été j'étais plus
j'étais plus débutante mais je me suis
rappelé de sa fin samedi
vous avez vécu avec un fait qu un
canadien ont été michael sarrazin avec
un français et vic avec un manager
carrus ou non
qu'est ce que vous préférez c'est
lesquels les mieux la maison ça encore
c'est une question je ne laisserai pas
tomber dedans avant non vous mais chez
moi
oui mais tout à fait oui non je crois
qu'il faut garder certaines choses à
l'exclusion vous tirez pas à me le dire
quelle conclusion vous tirait sur le je
pense qu'il ya toujours les individus et
l'individuel tous les pays
je veux dire que j'aime bien l'homme
moderne vous allez vous marier
non non je vais pas vous marier voit pas
beaucoup plus pour quoi
c'est pas que je ne veux pas c'est que
je trouve que ça ne marche pas plus
beaucoup en jeu c'est d'être un pas en
avant
j'essaie d'être plus intelligent qu'eux
il ya quelque chose là dedans qui en
paraissent les gens je crois et moi j'ai
tendance
vous avez peur de tomber dans la routine
non parce que j'aime bien la routine aux
instances non ses passagers j'ai peur du
manque de respect je crois que c'est ça
entre les personnes mais je trouve que
l'aspect c'est très très important dans
leur amour et
je ne peux pas dire que la mariage cas
ça au contraire ça peut être quelque
chose pour 21% fin juin
c'est la fête conséquent à quelque chose
et on ne traite pas avec ce centre
s'inscrit à la bouche vous appelez
jacqueline bisset ou jacques ibis est
oui a dit oui mais vos parents vous
appelle comment jacques et jacqueline
jacqueline jacqueline ouy evo jules tout
plein d'autres choses à bourges en quoi
db oui bébé en plein jackson
jackson geely c'est geely oui c'est vrai
c'est comme le whisky
oui c'est en reste et vous êtes à la
fois très très proche de nous parce que
vous avez une mère d'origine française
vous avez un nom qui fêterait exilés
français en angleterre et vous avez
tourné dans la nuit américaine
je vous aimais bien paris vous êtes
aussi assez assez lointaine parce que
vous tournez dans d'énormes
superproduction américaine et vous
faites très attention à ça fait très
attention à votre code dans le box
office
non non non c'est vrai que vous regardez
le budget d'un film avant de lire le
scénario
non pas tellement jeu j'ai fait beaucoup
de films de granby j'ai mon budget mais
récemment j'ai fait beaucoup moins ce
que d'ailleurs j'aime beaucoup les films
en thé indépendant d'esprit il faut
suffisamment d'argent pour faire un film
tout de même cédé pan d'histoire mais je
crois qu'on peut en faire un bon film
vivre bon petit film pour dans l'est en
amérique en sont pas déjà 4 4 millions
et demi il semble impossible par exemple
au dessus du volcan ses dépenses et non
saison mais pour toutes les
superproductions américaines vous avez
fait genre the deep tycoon joli tout ça
vous aviez claverie m'en cacher à peu
près d'un million de dollars du fonds
non non moi
non j'ai pas envie parle d'argent un bon
nom mais beaucoup moins que ça à ces
postes avaient choisi des films quand
j'ai fait le dip mais ça m'aurait
vraiment tellement pris beaucoup
c'était un énorme succès
mais quand j'ai eu ces bolides j'étais
que je t'écoute comment j'avais fait pas
moi j'avais fait très peu de fini tout
est aux anges étaient bonnes histoires
étaient jetés paient pas beaucoup je lis
sous contrat d'ailleurs à cette époque
pour riches et c'est là que vous avez co
produits finis et productrice et ça vous
donne envie de recommencer ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous êtes content
doivent beaucoup aimé le film l
expérience était trop proprié s'était
pas heureux je suis très contente
maintenant ça m'a sorti beaucoup de mes
contradictions je crois parce que je me
suis en fait ça m'a de fait devenir
adulte presque cette expérience et être
rentable oui c'est une expérience qui
venait peu à peu mais là ça j'aime
beaucoup je me suis trouvée pendant ce
temps là j'ai senti un peu ce que c'est
hollywood avec les messieurs qui se dit
maja dans les majeures qui est toujours
eu la grève en plein milieu oui mais
c'est pas ça qui était gênant c'était
que je me suivent j'ai dû prendre
prendre changement
ce londres selon le mois de piété de
plus est juste une actrice qui était je
crois que c'est difficile pour une
équipe qui ont l'habitude que vous soyez
actrice vous voilà en train de dire bon
message n 3 où c'est chez moi
non c'est pas ça c'est que c'est moi
j'ai comme personne je suis quelqu'un
qui aime bien avec l'équipe j'aime bien
parler j'ai bien peur qu à l'aide
et là je me suis senti trahi je vous
avais raconté dans
dans un journal anglais j'ai lu une
scène d'amour avec alan alda
manifestement ça se passerait si vous
êtes habillé en fait dessus doit souvent
oui on entend souvent un guînois collant
quelque chose de vrai vous avez dû se la
ville et de faire d'autre que vas-tu ses
côtés de la sto place partout oui oui
enfin bon moi je faisais plus dit
l'aimer parquet force habituelle de
perdre et une équipe mène plus public
comment avance ça c'est quelque chose
que toi quelqu'un qui y avait fait télé
vous avez tous vous avez joué dans une
feuille de stats anna karénine quoi on
n'a pas vu encore en france soir
commenté la banque
joséphine et napoléon vous l'avez bleus
et tournait finalement je ne sais pas
ces dessins qui l'a acheté jeudi
l'iphone je crois oui vous êtes sur les
cinq jours à saint ambroise il ya les
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou